i'm not a fan of it i'm um
[Music]
i probably won't won't get vaccinated to
until i got more facts and all that type
of stuff but now i'm not a fan of it at
all
what is your hesitation with getting the
vaccine if you don't mind me asking
i mean i haven't i haven't caught uh i
haven't caught cover yet so
i don't use i don't see me treating her
i don't
i don't see me treating covert until
i actually get cold i want everybody to
be vaccinated to um
to move more freely around the facility
and around as we're traveling and all
that type of stuff but i mean everybody
has their own beliefs and they are
entitled to their own decision
i haven't been vaccinated yet there's a
ton of different things that go into it
um i'm going to evaluate that on my own
and
uh you know make the best decision that
i feel like is you know again the best
for for myself
every time i hear that miles my first
thought is what what have you evaluated
why haven't you fully evaluated it yet
this is an issue that's been around for
months now what information have you
relied upon what are the pros what are
the cons do you have a sheet like when
walter white was deciding whether or not
he was going to kill the guy in his
basement or i think it was in i think it
was in jesse's basement do you have the
pros and the cons that you've put on a
legal pad have you really done the work
or is this just your way of running out
the clock changing the subject and you'd
rather say i'm evaluating things instead
of i ain't getting that shot i don't
intend to get it i'm not going to get it
and when i do evaluate it i am going to
lock on to anything i can find that
tells me i shouldn't get it well i mean
you get mata sweat saying i need to find
out more information and facts in the
same breath that he's saying i don't
like the fact that they brought in some
an expert on this to inform me of what
the facts are i don't understand that i
really don't i'll never understand it i
i there's
i understand that people are entitled to
make their own decisions and good for
them but at this point if you don't want
the shot own it you know stop saying i
i'm still evaluating i'm doing this i'm
doing that i need to do more research
everybody in this country has been
eligible to receive a vaccine for a
month now at least okay it's free you
can walk into your local walgreens duane
read rite aid whatever it is and get a
shot you can do it at the grocery store
i've been in the grocery store lately
where they literally said over the
loudspeaker if you're in the store and
you would like to have a covid vaccine
the johnson and johnson and pfizer shots
are available at the pharmacy okay if
you if you're not gonna do it you're not
gonna do it but own that and stop saying
that you're evaluating these things
because you're obviously not
because if you were then you wouldn't
still say you're evaluating it because
there's been so much information that is
readily available to you and teams are
providing it for you
so i don't want to hear anymore i'm
evaluating just say you're not going to
get it and own it
if you're sam darnold starting
quarterback of the carolina panthers you
have access to team doctors league
doctors union doctors and you could
contact the guy who writes the checks
the guy who has been ridiculously
successful the guy who has billions and
surely has access to top epidemiologists
who would be able to get on the phone
have a conversation with sam darnold
answer his questions put his mind at
ease if sam darnold really wants that he
doesn't and this is where it gets very
delicate for coaches and others in an
organization we've seen two different
approaches
generally you've got the coaches who are
being coaches like bruce erins
he was asked about bringing in a
specialist yesterday on the vaccine he
said i'm the specialist i don't see any
reason to not get vaccinated and you
know bruce aaron's isn't going to
hesitate to go into the locker room and
say to the guys get your vaccine
then you've got matt rule the coach of
the panthers who says i don't tell
anyone what to do matt rule understands
that this can create
division in the locker room matt rule
understands this can create resentment
you got ron rivera bringing in a vaccine
expert and you got montez sweat saying
publicly i'm not a fan of that not a fan
of the vaccine he's not a fan of
bringing in the expert
so this is a tough and delicate
situation for coaches and i think part
of what they're hoping guys will do
is that as they realize on their own
the benefits of being vaccinated what it
means to be vaccinated versus what it
means to not be vaccinated then they'll
choose to get vaccinated whether it's
not having to wear a mask whether it's
being able to leave town during the bye
week something peter king pointed out a
couple of weeks ago in football morning
in america or whether it's
the simple reality and miles there's a
good chance that the vast majority of
guys who haven't gotten vaccinated yet
who say they're gathering information
there's a good chance they have yet to
connect the dots from
not getting vaccinated
to
the possibility of finding out on a
saturday night you can't play tomorrow
because you tested positive today
because you're not vaccinated and it
happened this weekend guy got yanked off
the course leading
up in a tournament that paid out 1.7
million to the winner he was leading far
and away it was his
and he was told you're out you're done
you tested positive
and and i don't know how closely guys
who are in the bubble follow those
things but i think they're going to
start to realize it and the problem is
if you wait until the season's already
started and guys start missing games who
aren't vaccinated because they test
positive
you know it's going to take time to get
yourself fully vaccinated where you've
avoided that risk but i i think you're
going to have some regret from some of
these guys because you look at what
they'll do to get on the field
the things they'll take to get on the
field
the vaccination ensures that you're
going to be on the field and i just
don't know that many guys have figured
that out yet
i don't know why they haven't figured it
out yet mike i i don't know why i i just
i don't know and i guess this just stems
from what what what's going on with with
my life and whatever it is plug their
ears and they're not listening i guess
so but like
what what have you been doing for the
last you know year plus almost year and
a half that we've been going through
this
don't you want to stop going through
this
the way to stop going through this is to
get the vaccine there are millions and
millions maybe billions of people around
the world who would love to have the
same access to this vaccine that we have
as a country literally like i said you
can go to any
drug store you want and just get a shot
and people won't do it and i i don't
understand it in general in life i
certainly don't understand it in the nfl
i i don't get it and like i guess that's
just me i but i'm never gonna get it i
mean the second i could get a shot i
wanted that thing in my arm and i got it
i because i'm tired of this i'm very
very grateful i was able to do that
especially as soon as i was able to
because i was living in ohio but like
man i just i look at this mike i just
don't get it and i'll never get it
i made the argument yesterday that guys
who aren't vaccinated who land on the
cove at 19 reserve list this year should
not be paid last year hey anyone can get
it anywhere any place anytime there's no
vaccine no harm no foul if you're on the
covet 19 reserve list you still get your
game check this year
the vaccine's available
the facilities are generally safer than
the rest of the community given the
steps taken and given the urging to get
guys vaccinated if you're not vaccinated
and you can't play because of it you
don't get paid now d smith told
reporters yesterday players will get
paid if they're not vaccinated and can't
play due to covet 19 and players can't
be cut due to not being vaccinated and
we've heard that time and again the
league hasn't pushed for the permission
to
factor in vaccination status
in deciding whether or not to keep guys
but you know what
there's a reality i think the union
knows his miles
it's going to be a factor
and coaches and general managers having
learned from the example set by brandon
bean of the bills who said the quiet
thing out loud a few weeks back they're
not going to have a paper trail they're
not going to say it they're going to
know who's vaccinated and who isn't you
can't hide that guys wearing masks
aren't vaccinated guys not wearing masks
are vaccinated they're going to have
that information and montez sweat and
sam darnold don't have to worry about it
but you know who has to worry about it
anyone
who's spot on the roster is not carved
into stone
any of those other guys beyond the first
25 i'd say once you get beyond the first
25 players on the roster you're in
jeopardy well you know what if you're
not vaccinated you're in greater
jeopardy and and you could say oh they
can't do that well you know what they're
going to do it and you ain't going to be
able to prove that they did it because
at the end of the day it's going to be a
coaching decision and the union rarely
tries to poke through coaching decisions
now maybe they'll try to to fight a few
of these maybe somebody will say
something they shouldn't have said maybe
bruce erins would go too far in being
candid about his views but it's not
going to stop
these teams
from
considering that and why wouldn't you
why wouldn't you i got two guys who are
relatively equal in skill
one guy's vaccinated one guy isn't hell
yes i'm keeping the guy who's vaccinated
and the players need to realize that
the guy that cause that guy's gonna
allow you to move freely about the
facility better he's gonna allow you to
travel a little bit easier he's gonna be
able to do everything he needs to do
easier you know whether it's going out
on the weekend going out to dinner you
know on the bye week as you're saying
earlier like peter king pointed out you
get to travel and go where you want
because you've gotten this shot it's
it's a competitive advantage as well and
that's the start of the stuff we were
starting to see on these coaching staffs
right where they're talking about well
is the coaching staff vaccinated or not
you know if you're not vaccinated then
you can't be in the same room as the
rest of your players and that's a
competitive disadvantage at that point
so you have to do everything you can in
order to win right like that's what
these coaches are usually about and so
this at this point is getting vaccinated
or not getting vaccinated it it at some
point becomes a competitive advantage if
you do
and if you don't it's a competitive
disadvantage whether you're a coach or
whether you're a player and they
basically have made it around the league
so that people to support sas and
everybody those guys have to be
vaccinated because otherwise you're not
going to be around the players so
i just like i said i don't i don't
really understand not getting vaccinated
in the first place but maybe if they're
explained to in this way where it's yes
this helps us win
maybe that will help people understand
that this is something that we need to
do as a society not just as an nfl team
because it's a public health crisis
the most common justification given for
everything a football team does is that
it was in the best interest of the team
it is in
the best interest of the team to have as
many players vaccinated as possible it
is in the best interest of the team to
weed out the guys who aren't vaccinated
all things equal you got a superstar
you're not going to cut him josh allen
doesn't have to worry about being cut if
he doesn't get the vaccination anybody
who isn't josh allen you better be
damned sure that you're going to be safe
you better talk to your agent you better
have a an objective 30 000 foot
assessment of your career because you
may get a surprise come august 31 and
you may be on the outside looking in and
it may trace back to you not being
vaccinated especially if there's a
chance that you know coach has enough to
worry about on saturday night the last
thing the coach wants to worry about on
saturday night this year
is getting the email from the lab
saying this player this player this
player this player they're out for
tomorrow because they tested positive
and they're not vaccinated so guys need
to understand that
if if you want to enhance your chances
of making your salary this year you get
vaccinated and you think about all the
crap you've taken over the years to play
football whether it's
on the approved list or not how much
research have you done how much research
did you do into tour it all before you
took that shot for the first time or was
the only research necessary will this
make it stop hurting yes okay give it to
me oh you know what there's a chance
this may cause long-term kidney i don't
care give it to me so i think once guys
realize it's going to be an impediment
to their careers
that and and the problem is the teams
can't say it they can they can just put
out the breadcrumbs and hope that they
figure it out on their own
yeah well production equals tolerance
right you know the more productive you
are the more tolerant the team is going
to be of any crap you pull
that you know distracts from what it is
that we're doing or you know makes it so
that it makes it so maybe a little bit
harder for us to win so you know like
you said josh allen sam darnold those
guys are quarterbacks el monte sweat
he's a good defensive player all right
like these these are people these are
players that probably don't have to
worry about you know i'm not going to
get vaccinated so i'm in jeopardy
because of that like no not those guys
but like your run-of-the-mill guys
everyone else yeah well you're 40 to 53
on the roster
yeah it it's going to be something
you're worried about because it's almost
like what we were talking about with you
know the off season program right that's
voluntary and we know it's voluntary in
some ways for some people if you're
going to stay away then some rookie is
going to come in and take your job it's
the same sort of situation and i guess
maybe that's how we have to explain it
to people mike because i i just
obviously you know from a global
standpoint that we are in this country
like telling people like if you get the
shot it's good for you and it's good for
society that's not working you know the
levels have dropped off of people
getting their vaccines so i don't know
how we have to explain it to people that
makes it seem like it's good for you
individually but
maybe that would help
one last example before we take a break
especially this year with the salary cap
being 25 million lower per team than it
would have been but for the pandemic
you got a veteran
who's making 7 million this year
who not only
hasn't been vaccinated but is a vocal
force in the locker room against it
he's on one hand on the other hand you
got an undrafted rookie making 700 000
he's been vaccinated he's looked pretty
good
you know how the coach processes
assessment of performance how much he'll
trust a guy he could be influenced by
that so i got a guy who not only has
refused to be vaccinated but he makes
seven million dollars i need that cap
space he's he's a disruptive force when
it comes to what i'm trying to get guys
to do
he's going to get a surprise on august
31. i don't know anyone specific who
falls into that category but it's just
an example of how it can go that's the
kind of research that the players should
be doing you're not really doing the
research about the vaccine you should be
doing the research about how the team is
going to deal with this issue
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports